it wasn't long ago that the American
actress Megan Marshall was seen as
injecting new life into Britain's staid
royal family marrying Prince Harry sixth
in line to the throne in 2018 but the
mix of transatlantic glamour and royalty
quickly turned toxic in the press with
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
criticised for a Jet Set lifestyle at
taxpayers expense and accusations in
return against some newspapers of racism
in an interview late last year Megan
hinted that it might all be too much my
British run said to me
I'm sure he's great but
as the British tabloids will destroy
your life there will be critics of the
Sussex a--'s decision to go their own
way
becoming financially independent they
say splitting their time between the UK
and North America while retaining their
royal status trying to have their cake
and eat it they're trying to cash in on
their celebrity status while maintaining
that higher level of which is royalty I
don't think those two things can go hand
in hand easily and the idea of using
your royal title to make money is
something which certainly the British
royal family has never ever entered into
before outside Buckingham Palace
expressions of support and regret
fragmented like the rest of the country
she's come from a different background
and he's come from a different
background but and they're trying to
make it work for both family it's just
two families isn't it trying to make a
situation worthwhile the UK press
carries the story on every front page
the Queen deeply upset we're told
apparently she wasn't even consulted in
advance Prince Charles and Harry's
brother William incandescent with rage
and this talk of civil war inside the
royal family it's the sort of gossipy
reporting that is so common and which
Harry and Megan seemed to think will
cease or reduce once they put a bit of
distance between themselves and this
institution but members of the royal
family sometimes forget that the
taxpaying public has a legitimate
interest in their extravagant lifestyles
Harry's uncle Andrew was reminded of
that in his disastrous televised attempt
to excuse his friendship with a
convicted pedophile Harry and Megan
meanwhile have already been removed from
the royal waxwork display at Madame
Tussauds but they're unlikely to escape
the media spotlight Jonah Hall al
Jazeera London